i love tai chi that's my favorite
wouldn't it be nice to see all the rich
people running around the ship sliding
that white ass all around that boat with
the p with the pole people in the
[ __ ] bottom button they just slaying
load of dicks village
i'm miss pat and i'm back to answer the
internet y'all already know
what you give me this [ __ ] for don't
read out loud would you rather anyone be
naked all the time or clothes all the
time in this room in the world
everywhere you go everyone's naked but
then when it comes time to uh now i want
everybody to be clothed cause i
definitely don't want to see you naked
and your friend with that pink face and
pink
dick i don't want that tropical dick
[ __ ] no i want your clothes on if it
face pink can you imagine what a wing
wing look like i can't call it no dick
is still growing
paul the internet would you rather be
filthy rich in the 1900s of poor now
we were slaves in 1900s
[ __ ] rich just make me free wait a
minute was that the 1900s
no not slaves but it probably wasn't
good nineteen what is slavery
oh wait a minute one no slavery
[Laughter]
i don't know where they let you black
people free okay would you rather be
filthy richer than 1900 or poor now i
won't be rich goddammit
can you still go to your barber if he is
very racist barbara they got where we
ain't nobody couldn't know black woman
hell no this [ __ ] grows slow and you
[ __ ] crazy but i can deal with the
racists
hey the person who did your hair was
racist you all go with it
[ __ ] no
my dead is ain't racist he uh undercover
leave my goddamn this is a good old
christian man
would you rather spend the rest of your
life blind or inside an oligoid
oligarchy
[ __ ]
hey that salad is a [ __ ] them
breadsticks oh them breadsticks make
your vagina moisture moisturizer is that
the right word that salt make it click
sweller
you can turn any move into a porno with
the same cast from the movie which movie
are you picking titanic
oh i love tai chi that's my favorite
wouldn't it be nice to see all the rich
people running around the ship sliding
that white ass all around that boat with
the p with the pole people in the
[ __ ] bottom button they just slaying
load of dicks village
[Laughter]
which nfl team would win all white
players or all black players all the
best white players in football all the
best black players
you really ask a black person black
people yeah you can throw the bible who
the [ __ ] gonna run the touchdown
god damn you put the [ __ ] on the other
side
yeah who the [ __ ] gonna run the
touchdown russell burger can't run no
touchdown oh bigfoot slow foot ass man
don't you crazy unless they buy racial
what you gonna do with about rachel
people they black people they gotta go
on outside
back to hockey for y'all
would you rather lose a leg i'd never be
able to have sex again i'm all [ __ ] up
a couple legs off
would you rather be good looking and
always have nice clothes but smell like
[ __ ] or look like a homeless person but
smell nice i rather smell good because
when my vagina can't take a day off
i gotta watch my [ __ ] around the clock
or else it'd be pink like your friend
there
would you rather have fifth fifth grade
what's this fifth grade 50 grade
straight
50 grand 50. oh 50 grand i'm great
goddammit
would you rather have 50 grand to to
your bank account or half a million in
pennies
and you can't convert it give me them
goddamn pennies we got the rolls i'm
gonna drag them [ __ ] around like my
uncle cece used to keep them in their
pants
[ __ ] give me the half of me
they're gonna fill up a house on it you
know
he's like my brother my brother just got
last time i was here y'all made of me my
brother was in jail he out yeah
yes
kovy got my brother out the [ __ ] had
asthma and they let him go
[Laughter]
thank god for cozy
shout out to the legend ms pat for
coming through and answering the
internet there's anybody out there you
think can do what miss patches did leave
a comment below who do you want to see
answer the internet make sure you click
subscribe so every single monday a new
episode appears on your feed and hit the
little bell icon anytime answer the
internet drops any sort of content
you'll get a notification